The algorithm you just looked at would work if Robby were a person. But Robbie
is a robot, and only knows how to do very simple tasks. Moving to the first
place where he sees a yellow before a blue is too complicated. He can only do
simple tasks. So, he could move all the way to the left. Or, he could move all
the way to the right. He could move one space to the left or one space to the
right. He can check if the block right in front of you is yellow or blue. And
he can check if the block, just to his right is yellow or blue. I'm going to
have you write some pseudo code, but so that I can help you check it, I'm
going to give you some of the structure up front. Use the pseudo code commands
over here to write pseudo code to move Robbie to the leftmost yellow brick
that's followed by a blue. These lines are scrambled. Can you type them into
the right positions? You might need to type a line more than once.